my name is chiang phuo
i normally live in hong kong but this
year i'm here in berlin because
i'm the artist in residence at the
gropius bao
i'm not a scientist i'm an artist
my primary concern these years
is the climate crisis and also i would
call the
the extinction crisis i think in order
to address
these really planetary crisis
as artists i have to work with
scientists but i also work with
people in humanities in social science
etc because i think it's you know
in order to address these large issues
it's really
something we have to come together from
all the disciplines
in the event it will be conversations
between me
as an artist with plant scientists
i think the conversation is very
important because we have very different
approaches
you know i'm interested in how
scientists study plans
what they have learned about plants i'm
learning from their
their research i'm in conversation with
them
to kind of think about how we can see
plants differently how we can understand
their existence not only as biological
but also as
political because we tend to see our
life as not only a biological existence
you